and some breaking news for you here the
very first picture of King Charles III
uh His official picture post coronation
um we understand that his majesty is
pictured in his full regalia in the
throne room at Buckingham Palace he's
wearing the robe of estate you can see
there the Imperial State Crown and is
holding the sovereign's orb and
Sovereign scepter with the cross which
if you watched um the coronation here on
Sky News on Saturday you would have seen
him being handed during the coronation
ceremony he's Seated on one of a pair of
uh 1902 Throne chairs that were made for
the Future King George V and Queen Mary
for use at the coronation of king Edward
VII so this is the very first picture
here coming into our SAT Sky News of
King Charles III after his coronation of
course we're still on day three of the
celebrations for the coronation weekend
and um he is there wearing his robe of
estate holding the sovereign's orb and
Sovereign sector uh in the throne room
at Buckingham Palace